[Musique]
salut je peux toucher ta saucisse ton
chien
[Musique]
ordonnance de ces idées
et c'est ça le problème hier soir encore
je me disais il manque cet
[Musique]
c'est mon cousin je te le jure c'est mon
cousin c'est mon cousin éloigné
[Musique]
pour qu'il s'épanouissent avant d'entrer
à la fac et nous vous donnerons une
voiture sortez et entre guillemets c'est
forcément une blague vu comme les
parents sont impliqués ça m'étonne qu'il
le député
[Musique]
pour notre fils vous devrez apprendre à
le connaître pas juste sortir avec lui
mais aussi sortir avec lui et elle est
plus loin j'irai carrément moi
et les bénévoles dans un refuge pour
animaux salut je peux toucher ta
saucisse quoi ton chien
ça te dirait que je te dépose chez toi
c'est pas du tout le bon chemin c'est un
raccourci qu'est-ce que tu vas me sortir
19 ans tu es plus un bébé
tu en es où avec ton petit jeune on sort
ce soir il va prendre un long Island Ice
Tea j'ai le droit d'être ici arrête
d'avoir peur de tout j'ai j'avais pu en
Ice-T aussi dégoûtant
on se fait un bain de minuit et les
requins il y en a pas ici et les méduses
il faut éviter
ce qui est bien quand on vieillit c'est
qu'on s'en fout de ce que les gens
peuvent penser vous n'avez rien à faire
ici je vous demande de sortir allez sors
[Musique]